hey everyone guardians of the galaxy vol
3 is probably the biggest mystery of the
future the Marvel Cinematic Universe
what that is after Avengers 4 of course
but we have an update on the production
and a possible new director Sam Sam will
talk about the guardians of the galaxy
but first of all can the new rockstars
news everyone is there deep dive into
all the biggest of stories this week so
we're also gonna talk about a casting
update for Star Wars Episode nine Alec
Baldwin joining them leaving the Joker
movie Oscar Isaac and talks for the Matt
Reeves Batman movie and venom as a
trilogy
I'm your host Derek was joining me at
the table or Maude Garrett Phillip
Malina and Sam batcher great let's get
started actually with the top story the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 now this
week we learned that production for the
movie was officially delayed with the
pre-production crew dismissed by the
studio until they figure out who will
direct the movie of course writer
director James Gunn was fired by Disney
in July after a smear campaign by an alt
write troll freaked people out over some
old jokes that Gunn had long since
apologized for and moved on from I guess
was some weird revenge for Roseanne
which you know it doesn't make sense to
me but that's how the world works let's
look at this week there was a report
that Disney was meeting with thor
ragnarok director Taika Waititi to
possibly direct a future Marvel film the
report didn't say which movie it could
be guardians the galaxy vol 3 which
would be like the next thing that they
don't have a director for on their
docket or it could just be some other
Marvel phase 4 movie that we don't
really know about yet it was reported
that Marvel still intends to use James
Gunn's script for volume 3 which also
means his soundtrack will probably be
James Gunn's as well since he writes
scripts around his music choices and he
knew what songs were he wanted for
volume 3 last summer he actually plays
the songs on set when he shoots his
movies so whatever your feelings are on
James gun the way the industry credits
work he's still going to be listed as a
writer and a producer for volume 3 and
that also includes Avengers 4 since they
used his creations he's going to be a
producer in the credits on the Avengers
4 from what we can tell the studio still
intends on hitting a May 20 2008 and
based on what Gunn has said about the
movie spot vol 3 will conclude the story
of this iteration of the guardians of
the galaxy and
help catapult both old and
Marvel characters into the next 10 years
and beyond mister his words now we could
guess that the guardians of the galaxy
line up at least whichever of them
survived from Avengers 4 will return and
that Adam warlock remember who was
teased in the post-credits scene vol 2
will probably play some role in the
story and just coming out today Drax
actor Dave Bautista he's probably been
the most outspoken to the cast
throughout this story of defending James
Gunn this week he shared a tweet calling
out my externa [ __ ] who was that troll
conspiracy theorist on Twitter who
really led the smear campaign against
none a gun in the movie sort of it's
made a video and you could see it in a
video made by Victor gur and he was
bragging about creating false narratives
to tear down innocent people that's just
kind of what he does and he he doesn't
care he doesn't care whether it's true
or not
Batista said the vol.3 situation might
actually change the characters arcs in
Avengers 4 which is still going through
reshoots he said it's a kind of a
strange situation to be in now where
we've lost our director for guardians
it's on permanent hold for now and that
may make a difference in what they do
with our characters and Avengers 4 to be
honest with you right now I don't really
know but I know I'm in Avengers 4 I've
shot in most of it already I do have two
days of reshoots I better than that I
have some really great scenes that I
hope they use but I guess it remains to
be seen what they'll do with the
characters so guys assuming that they
won't rehire James Gunn which is what
they've said which directors besides
Tycho would TT would you like to be
considered to take over volume 3 what's
a smoothest way for this to go I sprung
that question on us that doesn't
actually involve talking about another
director apart from Tycho
if you'll indulge me go for it okay cool
two things one Disney learn about the
fact that when you have a lot of
tumultuous news and firings and rehiring
'he's around a movie that everyone's
anticipating it doesn't actually do well
in the box office on three one two three
solo justice yeah
sorry solo totally kind of just blipped
so it I forgot
has made more in their opening box
office sales so I just wish Disney would
just treat it with a little bit more
respect and not have something like a
right Alt alt right whatever it is party
who just want to tear down things I
don't want them to win and I have a
feeling that this is going to just yeah
put an ugly dent in in all the
production number two I think that if
they're gonna hire anyone it's going to
be tight over TD he's the only person
that kind of has that injected
successful humor I think Phil ragnerok
is one of my favorite Avengers movies
that have been there I just had a blast
maybe that's because he has Australian
Kiwi humor which is my humor
finally hmm but I would love to see what
he could do I don't think he's the only
one that could really do it justice
could help he could he could do great
but it's also like yeah other people
talking I could do it you know who
shouldn't do it Ron Howard but please
don't yeah just like waiting in the
wings I'm here but the you know I think
and here's frustration I think Joss
Whedon could do it but a lot of people
are mad at Joss Whedon because they
think that he's to blame for Justice
League and it's like the Snyder cut is
not we've seen Zack Snyder movies are
not amazing yeah so I think that movies
a mess for different reasons but Joss
Whedon like fully full force is a lot
like what Thor Ragnarok was if you watch
the later seasons of Buffy or Angel it
was like those kinds of situations with
like constant like jokes and like but
yet they still were like very high
stakes like a lot of people did die so I
don't know just would be cool but he has
his own his own problems get it what he
likes prime ribs yeah and then but my
real one is like the no brainer it's
always the easiest answer to give in
Hollywood Phil Lord and Chris Miller
yeah oh sure yeah this guy's more work
right because that's my thing I love
taiko to he'd be my number one choice as
well just because we saw he's a
proven choice right we saw what he did
with the Thor Ragnarok he knows how to
blend these worlds and kind of capture
the humor that James Gunn seemed to be
going for with the Guardians maybe not
the heart but not the heart and I would
say not necessarily the visuals cuz I
love the Ragnarok it seemed like the
first time Tyco was taking on a big
property that like was adapting visuals
and trying to create this kind of magic
on-screen well he got the tone it was
colorful and it was more colorful in the
tone in the humor than it was like an
actual action directing of the fight
sequences
I love the gladiator fight but other
than that all the the action fight
scenes kind of disappear in my memory
the one slow-motion Zack Snyder style
shot yeah it's it's a great movie I
don't want to take it away but I make
the movie in a - but it's it's you're
right those differences are we've talked
about different daredevil and Iron Fist
it's like the same fight style basically
and yet like daredevil we're all like
blown away and I can still remember
specific daredevil like fight moves even
though tiger I think would do a
fantastic job I love someone like Lord
amiloride Drew Goddard maybe who we know
with like the x-force movie never gets
like he's always so close to direct it
always just pancakes I would probably go
with Phil Lord and Chris Miller
even though type is great I'm just
picking somebody else that are picking
I'm just saying with that because you
guys with taike Phil Lord and Chris
Miller do have heart in their movies
it's different like I remember that the
lego movie actually they had like this
kind of like nebulous like companies are
bad well basically I just whittled down
to like this actually a pretty clear-cut
lesson that I'm blanking on right now so
that's obviously good it's but it'll be
a kid being yourself is okay but like
and like building up your own creativity
is a good thing but something like that
I'm gonna help me make a better point
the fact that Chris Miller and Phil Lord
have worked really really closely with
Chris Pratt
I basically have he's character but his
stuff yeah so everything is rad and they
build out like they're good at building
out worlds and their humors really solid
as well just get somebody who's got a
snappy ear for music Zach Braff if you
want to you guys ever listen to this
scrub soundtrack it's great there you
guys ever feel feelings like hey an
exact Brad does it he can crowd funded
on Kickstarter twice to see the movie go
three hundred million dollar Kickstarter
campaign you know pretend like scrubs
eating one of the best shows that's ever
been made I'm not have to prove is all
it is I get it I liked the shins before
the maybe that came in to put him on a
mainstream platform while I was a child
so I didn't post 2010 the I think you
guys bring up a good point that it is
about the team in the ensemble right cuz
that's what James Gunn did a really good
job of in the first Guardians and
continue in the second is like
cultivating this chemistry between
characters that normally on their own
wouldn't necessarily be developed he
kind of had to like the guardians of the
galaxy comics that he was adapting
weren't really a huge franchise and he
kind of established this team that we
all care weirdly about you know who who
of us 10 years ago would have been like
yes the guardians of the galaxy is a
team that I want it like sit down with
for two hours I think what is gonna be a
big challenge for whoever takes is over
if they intend on using gun script
you're gonna have to bring in a director
who can kind of create that sense of I
don't know synergy working from someone
else's script because a lot of the
directors we mentioned are kind of
authors they are accustomed to having
control over their own story breaking
story that's what happened with Phil
Lord and Chris Miller on solo where they
were writing off of a cast and script
and cat you know the cast and
father-and-son team are like yeah
they're like amazing screenwriters we
totally get it but they do not write in
the full lord chris miller style and
their choice on that was like well the
script is really just a set of guiding
principles right and turn out no no yeah
it's blueprints that you need to follow
it's a bit more boring yes it is yeah
well let us know who you would like to
see take over volume 3 of guardians of
the galaxy and and it's okay if you want
that person to look a lot like
James Gunn and have his name on his
driver's license and point out the
moment that Sam caught his posture all
right question oh this new one here okay
the question is what was the name of
Drax actor Dave Batista's first
wrestling character in question all
right all of our answers are here in the
bucket and I guess Drax is in this
picture but he's blending in so
perfectly with the background I don't
see him anywhere
later in the episode we'll reveal the
answer to the trivia question and the
closest answer as decided by our judges
will do or sign up goodbyes meanwhile
the loser will be inducted into our gif
of shame Club stay tuned for that later
she'll be it
okay star wars episode 9 released some
big updates this week we learned that
Matt Smith from Doctor Who and the crown
on Netflix will be joining the cast in
an unknown role along with Dominic
Monaghan from the Lord of the Rings and
the show lost he'll actually reunite
with director JJ Abrams and they'll join
newcomers like Keri Russell and Billy
Dee Williams who reprised lando
calrissian
and this week Oscar Isaac Poe Dameron
described the resistance in episode 9 as
guerrilla fighters adhering closer to
something like the Revolutionary War
fighters or even the guerrillas in Cuba
it with Che Guevara and Fidel Castro and
all these guys living in the mountains
coming down to do some attacks and then
going back and trying to hide from the
Empire of the United States in that
context hello yeah that's us the
Confederate States and it's actually he
said there was a sense it's kind of
ragged at this point and you hear
stories with like George Washington as a
general where like lots of people died
based on their orders but that is part
of leadership and that push and pull in
the fight of figuring out what is the
way to move forward so it sounds like
star wars episode 9 is actually set to
release on December 20th 2019 are you
guys excited it sounds like the news
come
about this movie it's all been good it's
all been like exciting crazy Matt
Smith's chin is it's a nation down guys
I was excited about this news and then
someone tweeted me going Matt Smith has
no eyebrows and it wasn't pointed out so
far with me show them again show me
again it's cutting off where are they
dresses
he got drunk one night but I'm excited
about Matt Smith who these two are
playing or here's my guest Rob this
right Oh Brendan I don't agree I think
on the left
I'm just so clearly seen like some like
grizzled poor not doing great kind of
guy which also Dominic Monaghan a little
bit but he plays like he plays grimy
pretty often in the Wolverine Origins
movie thank you very much so but yeah
he's like he just feels like somebody
who would be part of the resistance and
be like underground and then this is the
most imperiled looking mother father
I've ever seen like this guy's a Nazi
he's gonna be a villain base Nazis like
with a little bit of CGI work you could
get a maybe Jar Jar actually settle down
with more of a human girl and they had a
baby that had charger like quality's
just saying it could happen I'm liking
this barrel Jar Jar Binks meesa trained
my hardest to make money for the film
was saying that maybe men could be
playing Admiral Thrawn one of the
characters that actually survived
legends like it was originally a story
when the original trilogy was out and
that's it and he had a few books about
him and he's actually made the jump into
canon he's in revenues right he's the
blue admiral who works for the Imperials
and he's he and his race basically been
very clever
they're like so that son of George are
stolen interesting he able to set him
apart from
- yeah if he's just gonna peel any kind
of looks like thumb domhnall gleeson I'd
be like yeah sure yeah but if he's blue
yeah yeah so it I'm super excited by
Keri Russell I'm going through the
Americans right now and she's such a
good actress you know yeah it's it's
super violent a man-eating lizard not
necessarily Keri Russell has played this
great character of like you don't agree
with what she's doing but you get that
she believes in it and so you kind of
like get her motivation and so you can't
you're not like mad at her you're just
like man it's tough it's tough to be in
your situation yes to move to New York
to chase after a guy needed to go I'm
always talking she's maybe yeah
mission impossible this is about yo yeah
yeah yeah yeah do it then yeah oh boy
that's it's hard to look at what is the
sound effect of Felicity's eye turning
out it's like a weird little it goes
explosion right inside her head yes
right here like a charge like a and then
defibrillation I love that movie it's
great okay
the upcoming a Joaquin Phoenix Joker
movie directed by Todd Phillips had an
interesting casting story this week Alec
Baldwin was initially announced to join
the cast as Thomas Wayne father to Bruce
Wayne and had take on the role that some
described as a billionaire urbanite not
too different for the roles Baldwin
usually plays but then in an interview
with USA Today Baldwin announced that he
would actually not be playing the part
citing scheduling conflicts and saying
quote I'm sure there are 25 guys who can
play that part and production the movie
is set to begin on September 10th what
do you guys think happens you take out
one descriptor that was the big headline
was that it was Trump like and that was
the big thing and so and then the we it
was this weird exchange of interviews
that happened it was like Alec Baldwin
Thomas Wayne Alec Baldwin Trump like
Thomas Wayne then he and interview was
like no I'm not going to do that and
then like within like an hour it was
like and he's exited the movie it was
like ding ding ding and
was over anybody here that trump-like
thanked - that was a big headline
I know that Alec Baldwin hates playing
Trump he's like he's been pretty obvious
about that on his SNL performances like
you know he just he's just fine bones
it's just like a miserable role to play
and it's like you know it's to be that
person is probably it's gonna be hard
for him to sit in the makeup chair like
was like famously like a Democrat and
like a hyper liberal whatever so even
just to like look at that guy him and be
that guy's is probably pretty tough yeah
on him but also that's not Thomas Wayne
at all yeah Thomas weren't supposed to
be a really nice guy like a benefactor
or a doctor he's like a doctor who's
rich and like so and he held on to like
both of those things you wanted to help
people but also be rich but it depends
on what the story is cuz sometimes
usually he's tied with mafia as well
like there's always like tighter has
been yeah but there's one weird
interation where he's like tied to
helping Nazis get to America - there's
like a bunch of different iterations but
also I mean there's the version with a
flashpoint right with Thomas Wayne as
Batman and that I always thought like
what's-his-face
negan like like could have played like
such a great version of that which he
did I mean he didn't play that so that's
a angle I think would be cool is like if
you want to make him grizzled and like
almost Batman like himself that's cool
[Music]
he's great home alone - he's good
commercial so yeah it looks like this
cast already has like a lot of
supporting parts right Robert De Niro is
gonna be part of this it's easy beads
yeah I'm still trying to make out what
this movie's gonna be it's I heard some
description that it's gonna be like a
take on the Joker's and ATS failed
comedian like I just I just don't want
like it's so cool that with that it's
not there's no like official cannon
exactly of what it is and instead
they're like but what if there was and
what if it's the Joker played by someone
you don't like yeah what if it's in the
park yeah I'm watching me I'm walking to
Times
because Robert DeNiro yeah hey
show of hands who actually is excited
about this movie I'm excited about know
a lot of people on the camera I will say
the most popular version of Joker's
origin which is The Killing Joke I
watched that movie and it really is
weird to see someone who is a mass
murderer and a rapist and abuser and
then you try to make you then you try to
feel for him because he had a bad day
where he lost his job and then he gets
like me he does get like bleach and
that's awful but then it's like no no no
one bad day and you get to turn into
this person it's a weird lesson and it's
really stupid a little weird but that's
why I think is good about The Killing
Joke because more including that line of
if I had a past it would be multiple
choice like I think that's the the
version of the Joker where we did see a
backstory but then people walked away
from it like well could we really trust
him as a reliable narrator in that and I
think that's what Nolan used for the
whole Dark Knight the Joker is he has a
mysterious backstory and yeah I agree I
don't we've always obsessed about the
fact that like the judge the reason the
Joker exists in that movie is not to be
just another villain right it's like
we've had villains we've had generally
motivated villains that idea of a man
who just wants a lot to world burn
that's the idea of pure chaos that to me
is true the Joker which is why it's like
I actually don't need the pure force of
chaos I literally think of it as a force
of nature like a tornado entering like
the tornado doesn't need motivation it's
it's one of the few times where I feel
that way but the joke is one of the few
characters that works that way I
wouldn't mind if a tornado had
motivation and that's just wind dancing
let's move on to another update this
week is staying in the DC world Oscar
Isaac was reportedly approached by
Warner Brothers for an undisclosed role
in a that forever upcoming Batman movie
directed by matt reeves where does the
studio plans to reach out to an a-list
actor to play the villain rumored to be
the penguin but you know guys with ben
affleck probably not playing Batman
didn't hurt to let us go Isaac try on
the cow just for kicks right he's a
beautiful man he's great he was just
like Swain - yeah yeah so are you guys
excited you be interested in seeing Poe
Dameron Oscar Isaac be the next Dark
Knight
will he ever top his amazing role as
apocalypse and he could be but he also
could be like so many of the villains
yeah I could even see him be like
Clayface like I think Clayface is like
one of the perfect characters you could
have for a detective driven Batman movie
because you never really have him being
a detective you have it kind of like
solving some things but if you had a
character they could shape-shift
constantly and he is as dashing as Oscar
Isaac and you can't keep track of where
he's at and I clayface's origin is so
interesting - it's like it's just an
it's an actor a struggling actor who's
just like there's a lot of really cool
elements you could do also hashas pushed
a lot someone who looks a lot like yeah
Bruce Wayne who's obsessed with them and
he basically uses all of his villains
against Bruce right could be a cool
character too and like so obviously like
yeah he could do like to face this up -
right Blake he could do but I guess the
poor Mike he's like he could play like
any part and I'd be pretty daddy I don't
there you go yeah yeah let us know what
you think about Oscar Isaac as Batman he
I mean if Jake Gyllenhaal's not gonna be
playing the role especially if he's
gonna be in spider-man far from home it
could really be anyone the world is our
oyster but lastly this week venom star
Tom Hardy announced that he and Sony
might actually be making an entire
trilogy of venom movies in an interview
he said I'm open to whatever you want to
do with it we're sorry when you wear
that
you happy their responses are - no one
knows what you're saying he said I think
it's an awesome character I love playing
both of them it's an amuse-bouche
four and four it's the venom verse
launched in isolation as so what do you
guys think is this the idea of a venom
verse get you excited do you think it'll
have subtitles ever venom starts talking
you guys remember where they when they
actually had to change Bane's sound
mixing room so that he comes through
every speaker whenever you're like
watches just like your phone yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean I think it's kind of a
no-brainer for Sony from their
perspective right they need a big
franchise that's kind of all their own
to make many many money have we seen a
movie and the movie has set it up for a
sequel but the movie didn't do so well
so we never really knew what happened
that's very fun I mean like so exact
like the amazing spider-man 2 that had
this big sinister six post-credits scene
where movie that never happened yeah
that's a good point I think I mean to go
back to when they first announced the
venom movie I I still have to like honor
my feelings there where even though I've
seen some cool stuff since then it's
like I don't really want venom without
spider-man at least in like some huge
way I could definitely see them doing
you know a more expanded carnage based
storyline yeah which they suppose
they're not doing in this many trailers
yet but at the same time it's like I
don't know I I didn't I was never like
in love with Eddie Brock as a character
to have him be the home of all trilogy
it's just so obviously Sony being like
the trailer views are good maybe this is
our thing yeah yeah and they are good to
their credit okay people are pretty
surprisingly pretty excited for this
people also slow down in traffic when
there's a car accident that's true I
don't think it's gonna be that rough I
mean we have a town irritated for this
movie I think we're like a psychopath
butcher your head the car wreck of
Marvel mangled bodies are interesting to
paint
oh thank God you wanna know it's like
yes like that's it
like what do you do you have carnage see
of another turd mush monster and then in
the third movie was like a buffet of
like things move they make fertilizer
beer it's like no but whatever come up
with something more wolves will you even
have a pitch meeting about of course but
I like hear your point that like it's
the whole reason why the Transformers
movies never work for me as I I'm lost
I can't is that aluminum foil zoomed in
or they fighting but if it's just like
oil and like red oil yeah what's the
cohesion in out in yeah well let us know
if they do pursue a venom trilogy I'd
like to know what kind of villains you'd
like to pursue beyond carnage we're just
gonna go through some other symbiote sir
they're gonna apparently Sony has the
rights to nine hundred Marvel characters
so really talking about animated at
sinister six they could do but I I
really have a theory that they're going
with sinister six in this spider-man far
from home I think that's gonna be why
not
because there are so many bones that
they keep yeah there's yeah they have
great spider-man villain so yeah the
characters count like when you say
there's a bunch of Superman characters
like Jimmy Olsen and it's like it that
doesn't mean that they're all you know
it's like we're sure they have 900 non
super-powered characters from the Marvel
yeah we got may Uncle Ben Jameson's
managing director son he's an astronaut
I don't care please stop
yeah alright let's move on to our new
rocks there's news lightning round just
questions we're gonna fire them at
Microsoft the answer them as quickly as
possible
with Philip Parker abroad Rahl wants to
know
that was literally how it's written yeah
what have you never what will you never
two questions what what I never have I
ever blank have you never and what blank
will you never I guess thing activity or
hey I think come up with a question what
do you like for example I've never sky
dived
I've never yeah I've never seen snow and
you will never see there's two questions
and what what will you never yeah what
something that like I'll never know if I
get paid 30 bucks
am i what will I never I will never do a
job I don't totally care about it all
what are you yeah there's a lot of ways
what be yeah go on
Yoda phrasing there for sure my kasi is
cool 9 wants to know if you had to
choose one of the dusted to stay gone
well some we saw on screen not just a
random person who got tested you mean
one of those two dudes behind you wanted
to stay gun good run
yeah I feel at least bad about that one
mm-hmm yeah yeah and if it's a hank pym
from the comics he's done bad stuff too
so yeah deserves to Sam hiking natural
wants to know what is your favorite Stan
Lee cameo Oh Teen Titans go to the
movies it's an amazing it can't be a
superhero movie without Stan Lee and he
like runs in and jumps on the front of a
windshield and he's like riding down the
street it's amazing it's such a good
life but from MCU it's when he's with
the watchers and guardians to where he's
like explaining all of his cameos it's
like one time I was a FedEx delivery man
that was lightning yeah all right Eric
from @v den Shama six one nine four EA
boss if you could be a villain from the
MCU for one day who would you like to be
and I'm gonna add and how would you use
their powers villain from the MCU
lightning Knightley that's right you
could do so much you get to be thanks
for all your questions okay now comes
the time for a 50 second shout out three
choices 15 seconds to shout out a plug
ramble about anything Sam yes hi there's
a Kickstarter that you should go check
out it's by unki it's for a little robot
named vector and it's a it's a little
the company's actually made a lot of
different a is that you could have in
your home but this is the first
autonomous robot it's like this big has
a little tractor thing in front of it
it's adorable and it can talk to you it
actually recognizes faces and stores it
so when you come home it'll say hi and
you can give it tasks to do and it'll
just kind of roam around your house like
a little cat check it out on key vector
look it up and support it cuz I'm gonna
get one and I'll bring it in
yeah it'll be a host clean my room yeah
well it's like basically like a LexA but
it runs around it has cute little eyes
I'll show you the video after okay the
TAS are probably like go from here to
there but comes down for my 15 seconds I
kind of mentioned this last week but
yeah if you live in the Los Angeles area
at the end of this month September 29th
in at the Acme theatre in NoHo I'm gonna
be doing a show called infinity fan it's
a it's a parody sketch show that's about
like Marvel and Star Wars and the DC
Universe kind of make it in there and
Game of Thrones basically the idea is
what happens if a superfan decides he
wants to
save every unfairly killed off character
in his favorite movies because he
believes he knows best how to tell these
stories would it be a good thing would
it be a hilariously bad thing
let's hope the former you'll see more
details I have a big firm announce if I
wanted to give you guys a whole yeah so
I'm very excited about it follow me on
Instagram and Twitter Eddie gave us for
all those details my 15-second shadow I
have a go see searching super cool movie
John Cho it's not an every theater but
if it is around you go see it it's a it
kind of is a non horror version of that
movie unfriended which is a pretty good
modern horror movie especially like a
gimmick based one but the searching is
not once a searching is not horror but
it's just one of these ideas of like an
execution an idea of what would actually
happen if someone you love goes missing
what is the actual work you would do and
I think they kind of had the realization
you'd be on your computer basically for
most of that time and that was exactly
like it like it really motivated the
usage of that that devices the whole
movie takes place basically on a mat
IMAX screen yeah but super great twist
super great storytelling it's very very
fun good one yeah my 15 seconds we
you'll find out on geek balm tomorrow
but I'm just announcing that functions
and flagons season two is upon us
understand flagons is a show that I do
on geek balm which is basically like an
introductory version of Dungeons &
Dragons without any rules so if you can
dream it you can do it as long as you
roll high enough Sam last time has been
a big part of funds and flagons and he
has no idea how to play RPGs and so it's
really hilarious I'm actually setting up
the patreon for that because you guys
helped me build the campaign choose
monsters items selections all that kind
of fun stuff so yeah basically plugging
not only my geek bomb shuttle but
patreon.com slash geek bomb bay and if
people like really you have trouble with
hearing geek bomb in my accent GE ek
beat me geek I'll be on me bomb B&B what
do you think they're hearing keep on
geek gik
geek bomb mmm it's like my name I've
gone from mode to mod yeah damn
different name it's a whole new name
well let's return to the trivia question
this week that I took earlier and the
reminder our punishment is the gift of
shame shame or just shame if you're
wrong the wrongest answer to the
question will have to draw a task or
gesture from the gif of shame container
which needs a better name peoplename
Porton that asked repeatedly where they
are and the winner will read our
goodbyes and the rest of us will chant
shame at you and your stupidity will be
turned into an animated gif which we
will blast out on social media to punish
you for your trivia ignorance everyone
good let's remind each other what's the
questions the question was what was the
name of Drax actor Dave Bautista first
wrestling character by era seems to
think it's Eric bloodsucker he liked
Eric's blood that's what he's saying
because you did notice he has fangs
that's not right
Sam ro I'm just Harry to be here that
says those are to pee and definitely to
zoom in on that that doesn't make any
sense I'm just happy to be here
you're just Harry yeah I am Harry you
could be Harry today house talk what's
going them in FEMA says Dave bad Mesa
bad Larry is in his name at all I get a
point
all right and mod wrote you wrote oh
that's pretty good
Dave and Buster's good the correct
answer let's say it together is
Leviathan it's yeah what is a Leviathan
is it a we okay what do you say too bad
mr. demisa
all right so Philip got closest and
farthest away and joining the gift of
shame I'm just Harry to be here these
are gifts of shame we need to more
clearly mark the container which
containers so many containers containers
one the task Brit shame pretend urine
Austria's trying to hide your whole body
behind your mug okay okay zag say many
yogurts camel the mug hold your mug
if you hold they bury their heads I got
you Harry be sure what kind of gift you
would use like what kind of
conversations we've been having to use
this gift me I know is when you your
co-workers trying to have a conversation
with you and you go hope he doesn't see
you take away our goodbyes Oh Jim does
this I never wanted to go ahead yeah all
right they're both hallo thank you for
watching this week's episode of new
rockstars news I want to thank our host
Sam basher at Sam basher Eric Voss a ta
boss make sure to check out that sketch
up here in LA I'm full Molina at Molina
at fimo and Maude Garrett of course at
Maude Garrett comment down below about
the stuff we talked about earlier and
tweeted us a new rock stars and like
this video and share it around and I'm
building up to something to be as really
quick I want to say we've got something
excited coming it come in like next week
and you guys were like tweeting me about
it like oh you're being so vague and
it's like oh well maybe I am but you'll
find out next week subscribe to new rock
stars for deep dives into the stuff you
love bye Amy
[Laughter]
well done guys